then there's the whole world of clean
energy technologies
the third world of technologies to talk
about now they are following the classic
tech
cost curve down and they're also hitting
the inflection point
of scaling up let's take solar which is
the most dramatic and it's kind of the
classic example
we needed that last era the long boom
era to drive the cost down to compete
and undermine carbon energy it took 40
years but we're now there
when we began the last era around 1980
it was like 76
bucks a watt for solar power last year
was down to 22 cents that's a 350 time
price decrease
and what do you know we're watching the
ramp up going on the other side as those
costs came down the scaling went up in
exponential fashion in the last decade
we're now at about 700 gigawatts
globally still a long way to go to
displaced carbon
again but remember what the scaling of
digital technology was
in the 1990s in fact if you pull back
and look back in the last 20 years you
can
actually see how the installed solar
globally has
risen in logarithmic scale granted from
a very low
installed base but now the scaling
itself is driving the cost
down every doubling of the industry
installed base
drives the cost down 30 to 40 percent
which keeps up the virtuous circle of
growth
the same dynamic is happening in
electric vehicles in just the last
decade the cost of battery packs for
electric cars have been driven down
to be almost fully competitive with
internal combustion
engines but if you look out for the next
decade
they're expected to drop another three
to five times
and in the next few years or so they're
expected to be cheaper than internal
combustion engines and so across the
board better
easier to maintain safer and cheaper
fuel
and so what do you know you're watching
the ramping up just starting
we're still again just in the last
decade we're starting to ramp to about 7
million electric cars
were sold globally last year again still
a long way to go
but remember the 90s and the tech ramp
up